you got a phone video Victoria hey it's
Gary Vee I'm giving a speech to 2,000
people
listen to me I'm here with your fiancee
fiancee right yeah fiancee
pretty good-looking dude um anyway just
keep listening I promise you it's not
because I want you to listen to me it's
because what I'm talking about is
universal people long before me you're
talking about it too life is very basic
the second you stop hearing them both
positive and negative is the second your
life gets happier and the fact that
you're starting to get happier means the
world to me and I hope this video is
something you play over and over anytime
your old friend or some random person on
the Internet
it makes you feel bad you send them this
video hey person [ __ ] you you got your
perspective
be happy don't you want to be happy in
[Music]
2009 when I started making business
content more than half of the comments
that I got were for me not to talk about
business because I should because I
should only stick to wine cuz that's
what I know you know that is probably
you know I just said it for the first
time this clear icd rock in the
background making notes that way I might
not have something better to say right
now than that that more than half the
people that commented on my content in
2009 made snarky comments that I should
stay in my lane that I'm just the wine
guy and and I think that would be very
good for advice for a lot of people
because I know for a fact because I get
so many DMS the amount of people who'd
no longer want to be posting what
they're posting on Instagram but because
they were funny and a comedian but now
there are serious business person they
used to be a model but now they want to
talk about their vegan food business
they used to be a business serious
business man but now they want to be a
comedian there's a lot of peope
because the first time they post
something else especially people that
are attractive I feel a lot of empathy
towards people who are attractive they
they their self-worth and their likes
come from being attractive then they try
to make one post about something else
and it doesn't get as many likes and
they feel insecure and they'd rather get
likes than be happy which is crazy so my
biggest advice number one is
self-awareness number two make make make
everyone's thinking they're working
towards it they're looking for their
videographer all these [ __ ] excuses
to not make people come up with a
hundred excuses they're insecure they're
scared they deep down don't think they
can achieve what they're saying they're
gonna achieve
and so they're not making number three
is patience yeah I cannot understand how
people think that in a week or in a
month or even in a year they're gonna be
so famous and so rich and so it's it's a
delusional and so patience so my
question is which is the most ordinary
thing in your life that brings you more
joy and you can bring from their life
extraordinary energy this is a very
funny question I don't know how much
garage saleing there's done in Brazil
but do you know what crush you know when
you go to somebody's yard yes and just
sell stuff mmm-hmm that is by far the
most ordinary thing that brings me the
most joy oh I think it's the thrill of
the hunt you know you pull up and you
don't know what's gonna be there it's
about knowledge there's things that I
know are worth money on eBay that other
people don't and sometimes I remember
this one couple months ago we went to
Germans house he had a huge collection
of 2000 Olympic pins 36 37 38 39 40 41
pins on the first thing he wanted a
dollar piece I'd be 20 for the whole
thing and boom and boom okay it was very
cool we bought it for like $40 and it
was worth $2,000 and and the high and
that just it's a very simple thing go go
wake up at six o'clock in the morning
and go garage sale but I think it speaks
to Who I am which is I love business I
love the thrill of the hunt I love the
process
I like that stuff so that would be a
[Music]
it is pork Brazilian audience awesome in
the stories so to any kind of culture I
gotta you have to to the Brazilian
audience we just publish that video for
you is this is the Brazil page yes
Portuguese Portuguese yes that's right
what's up everybody its carry me
I'm so fired up to be in Brazil about to
take the stage I've made a huge
commitment a huge idea right now I am
going to learn how to speak Portuguese
I'm kidding I'm kidding I have no
ability to do that yes
thank you so much what's up everyone
I am Jesus this is the best voice I ever
[ __ ] heard what up guys sitting
backstage here in Brazil about to give a
keynote and post it on Facebook and on
Twitter for that matter the worst
complaints you've heard put out some
content about complaining which i think
is a really vulnerable state and then
ask people leave comments with the worst
complaints they've heard here are some
of the ones that the team thought were
funny so I'm gonna read them just first
time I'm reading them here we go number
one my mom didn't wake me up for work
this is a 24 this is gonna be a funny
video like just a thought first of all
my mom didn't wake me up for work was a
terrible excuse in 1984 because you know
relying on your mom to be at work is
ludicrous in 2019 it's [ __ ] absurd
you have alarms on phones like like
excuse next a few weeks ago my coworker
complained that there was too much of
the bacon in his breakfast burrito you
know I'm not sure this was a heavy
company I want to know the tone
I can't imagine somebody getting super
angry that being said one of the things
I've been telling my team about is one
of the reasons I'm empathetic to my
trolls to those heavy negativity is if
you're that sad that you're putting out
venom against another human being
you're probably hurting inside and so if
this person was actually complaining
about too much bacon in their burrito
what I'm really thinking about is what's
actually going in their lives that could
trigger you too much bacon in a burrito
triggering means a lot of sadness deep
down inside number three I heard someone
complain on a cruise that their cookie
was too soft
I mean that's just my same answers
number three and there's anything else
to say number four I can't catch a break
that's an interesting one after telling
me they are almost all caught up on all
their Netflix shows that's a really good
one Brian I I think you know nobody's
giving me a job all my bosses suck I
can't catch a break
the system is rigged all loser talk for
people that tend to not want to do
action non motivated because they
haven't found their passion or they
haven't found a happiness zone or they
grew up in entitled environments where
everything was paid for so they don't
even know how to go and get it I will
always always repeat this when you're
overfed it's hard to be hungry and so
let's make sure we balance it either
you're insecure or you're entitled and
both are dangerous complaining is the
tail to unhappiness stop [ __ ]
complaining and start creating solutions
[Applause]
hey guys so d rocks innovating which I
appreciate you're a good idea post this
21 minutes ago 50,000 views really solid
good start
more importantly you probably see this
is probably now the third one two three
four third video that we've put out that
forth that is incorporating a mean video
that's doing well on Instagram and then
layering our two cents on it you know
instead of just posted a video we put
our own kind of take on it and then I
put something at the top this one's love
to learn adversity instead of fearing it
what's really interesting about this
post is quite long copy you know because
it was you know a video where I'm not
speaking or it's not me
context DJ really matters and the way I
can DJ add my two cents to this like any
great a DJ an EDM in deep house and
anything of that nature they're adding
their element so that you don't feel
like it's just a Rihanna song right and
so what what you can do on social
networks is add a lot of copy and this
is where people who are great at words
that might not be as great at videos
have a way to shine you might actually
be a better DJ than a songwriter
original content is like songwriting but
adding a lot of sentences to take your
observation or how you see something
that's already in the zeitgeist is a
great form of DJing a lot of people Raz
on DJ's for taking hits and just adding
to it but I think we all figured out
over the last 20 years that was a skill
set and an art that we ended up enjoying
and so for me that's the insight on this
post and I hope that brings you value
yeah awesome that's around mr. what's
real pleasure so I don't know what's the
deal with this it's my favorite number
okay why I was thinking that happened
when I was five itself like China yeah
at five I decided my favorite number is
gonna be five I'm starved and it [ __ ]
stuck and should be swish every year I
know like forty three [ __ ] and
it's stuck and then like five three
years ago I'm just taking so many Sufis
and I was like man I'm just gonna
[ __ ] do that I just did it once and
there's it twice and just stuff and now
there's like it's really funny like now
once in a while I see people do it in
the wild and like just without you do it
so yeah it's so flattering it's so cool
so cool I thought I was like Jethro
Anders I'm sure you know what's funny it
weirdly is a little bit so my mom pat
leahy when I was a kid back okay but my
mom decided to knit me a sweater because
we couldn't afford a jet or Jersey
there's like well you know my most
prized possession I talk about a lot
like when I buy them I want to put it in
the entrance of the stage like it's my
thing right cuz we couldn't afford a
[ __ ] shirt yeah so my mom made me one
and she asked me what number and I said
five and so it does have a little of
that it is cool it's like you know when
something actually means something to
you instead of like not actually yeah
hello my friend how are you I'm very
well how are you I'm fine I'm good to be
your voice thank you do you now to say
[ __ ] and then we're then this is all set
fair enough I've been watching a lot of
your video thank you thank you anything
I can answer for you anything
what is the I don't I don't know you
have no idea
now it's gonna be stand watching it's
gonna be in that range all right how
about speed how fast do you normally see
on that fast side as far as you saw
you've seen the videos like that you
want me to try to slow down a hair I'm
gonna I'm gonna truly try I don't know
if I can but I will really try getting
prep yourself first time the country
which I'm really excited about
I give this whole speech in Portuguese
which is unprecedented Iraq I'm more
worried about the Iraq making his flight
than
I'm not flying down here to tell you get
quick rich move there is no hack there's
no [ __ ] shortcut it doesn't exist
when it does it lasts for 11 months and
then it's over the only thing you need
to chase is figure out what the [ __ ] you
want to sell that you believe it that
you believe in and the second you
understand that you got to figure out
how you're gonna tell the world about
the product you believe in words videos
audio and then you start making and
getting very patient slow slow slow
the number one thing I think is slow the
number one thing that most people hate
is slow that's the [ __ ] game
thank you for self
[Applause]
I said we're going out here d-roc is
gonna miss his flight there's a good
talk hi Santa what's that speaking
speaking for deuce aha [ __ ]
[Applause]
[Music]